jean michel lemaire c'est la boîte à
poux qui il ya des poux qui sur tout le
monde bien entendu et guillaume genton
aurait été aperçue à la sortie d'un
salon de massage douteux il aurait du
mal à justifier sa présence sur le site
jean michel mr cvo la source mais
décidément ces mamelles guillaume genton
excusez moi n'est ce pas possible j'aime
expliquer non même
moment un moment on va avoir des
problèmes avec vous gilles c'est très
grave
et c'est vrai alors mais je peux
expliquer malaisie parce que voilà
c'était une quinzaine de jours j'étais
au spectacle jean luc lemoine à pigalle
et en sortant à 10h30 on secoue toujours
pas en scooter dans une petite rue
adjacente je vois mon guillaume genton
sortir d'un salon de massage du secteur
voilà c'est mon massage chinois du coup
je m'arrête je papote deux secondes avec
lui et il me dit qu'il sort qu'il est en
train de préparer un documentaire sur
les salons de massage parisien qu'il
faut produire est avec vous voilà donc
voilà donc j'aimerais savoir comment l
enquête a donc et la sortie de son
documentaire c'est prévu d'inculper quoi
en tout cas alors c'est un projet qui
était sous embargo je voulais pas en
parler pour l'instant en train
d'enquêter sur le terrain adverse et
votre carrière qui va toujours barrio
non mais c'est un vrai documentaire de
catherine ça s'appelle massage thaï les
coulisses d'un business juteux ça
sortira très bientôt au cutter
sais pas si le titre c'est très bien ça
tire de toutes tailles en tout cas pas
sur ces 8
c'est toi tu sortais doux parce que le
spectacle avait le dialogue s'est
terminée à 21h30 et lui par innoven 2h30
d'antenne mais j'ai eu du mal à démarrer
moscou tout ce qui
[Rires]
et moi vous étiez tous les deux pas se
mentir je pense que le feu claquent de
jean luc lemoine le pauvre lui qu'il a
bon dos je pense qu'ils ont élevé un
autre spectacle merci roger laboureur
delphine se serait endormi le soir de
son anniversaire donc et avant-hier
alors que delphine avait prévu des
dessous sexy et une nuit de folie
chroniqueur anonyme qui veulent bien de
delphine qu'est ce qu'on décore des
jeans c'est vrai
d'autant plus vrai qu'il a d'énormes
problèmes il a une sorte de maladie qui
fait qu'il dort tout le temps il s'est
endormi en logis d'autres il est de la
tête juste avant il a il a fallu qu'elle
rend le film a grandi ni l'éthique
oui très
alors effectivement tout ça est vraiment
très marrant mais ce serait fantastique
si on pouvait passer à autre chose
puisque roger va très bien nous sommes
très heureux
que c'est un faux pas fait bien sûr oui
naudinet de la tête demandez à vos
équipes il a presque fallu gérer
l'egypte pour qu'il se réveille avant de
venir
c'est
alors la réveiller accepte chaque matin
à merde et sia ah oui c'est moche
chaque matin la première chose que fait
cyril aux menaces et de vérifier son
classement de paddle tennis sur une
application alors que le classement
dévolu qu'une fois par semaine et qu'il
ne peut donc pas avoir gagné deux places
tu approches de syrie qui a dit ça
beinheim âge à vous dire que ça fait
matthieu delormeau pas du tout mais en
même temps on au quai janvier non non
c'est que je ne mens jamais c'est pas
moi c'est qui
c'est passé qui est ce que c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais c'est le
coeur balançait ses benhaim met pas le
feu
c'est vrai ça vous obsède et un bon on
va le dire la vérité c'est vos équipes
c'est lionel est ce que pour de vrai tu
triches surtout quasiment pas du tout
voiture il est mérité on ne peut pas
tricher
informatisé avec de l'argent on peut
tout faire d'argent des gens mais sans
argent on peut tout faire barry vous
merci à encore civil civil seconde de
faire attention à sa ligne alors que
chaque matin expect le bidon réchauffer
au four des croissants ou des pains au
chocolat le tout arrosé de poissons
pétillante mais lime
c'est bon tu sais pas moi mais je mais
je dis que c'est vrai parce que je le
sais mais c'est pas moi qui ai balancé
sur ce qu on a droit de manger de la
matin rappelez vous avant de
l'abandonner dernier à pâques et des
mecs comme ça dans la rue j'étais avec
vous avant l'enregistrement et et c'est
normal et des boissons pétillantes dès
le matin quand c'est pas du tout des
boissons pétillantes c'est du jus
d'orange et in situ bosser autant pour
gilles
guillaume genton a demandé à la
production que son chien soit rémunéré
pour participer ou à pois foot mais non
la demande a été refusée sur ce gilles
verdez c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
ça a été très difficile à vivre pour les
équipes parce que les gens ont travaillé
énormément le soir pour ce prêt mais
vous savez il y avait un chien au régime
oui oui et bien son chien a été amené
par guerrouj en tout cas demandé
regardez derrière vous et il a demandé
d'immunisation à cachet pour un
maître-chien et heureusement la
production a refusé merci bah oui la
production refuse toujours les chercher
eux bernard montiel ses ventes et que
pour la première fois de son histoire
lundi dernier le 6 à 7 et était en top
tweets sauf qu'il a omis de préciser que
c'est grâce au petit train en bois
offert par cyril dans fmp source un
chroniqueur anonyme gilles verdez
jeffrey ils n'arrêtent pas de dire même
ça va au delà puisque hier il va
entreprendre tu as vu j'ai fait cinq
cent mille quand cyril mais paypal a
donc il a un melon pas possible
commencent à dire que quasiment c'est
vrai bernard vous me l'avez dit hier
voilà c'est faux et je vous vois c'est
vrai c'est drôle voilà un petit train en
bois et un présentateur en catch up
je tiens à dire que tout ce que tout ce
qu'on dit là c'est vrai bien sûr c'est
tout à fait légal s'il fait que des
vérités tombola ah ouais voilà donc
delphine refusent de l'avouer ça aulas
alors je ne savais pas alors allez-y où
il a carrément alors là à ce prix là je
savais pas je commence à marcher j'ai
fait une refusent de l'avouer mais si
elle est tombée amoureuse de roger c'est
parce que c'est un ex danseur strip
teaser très connu en alsace c'est vrai
alors alors oui il était strip tease
alors oui il paraît qu'on a des photos
alors elle est de 10 ans mais pas ses
efforts oui non oui parce qu'ils
faisaient du mannequin et quoi il était
même si
c'est lui il était ouvrier sur
mannequins pour la redoute il avalait
des vous l'avez connu la convertit des
stripteaseurs meba et moi je les
rencontre il ya cinq ans donc il est
content lui
est arrivé à roger
la matière aussi bon
mais il est très beau
lannion
il a pris un camion
d'autres rentrent en est maintenant il
faut traverser dans les clous
[Rires]
baillet d'affilée mal commencé très
sérieusement tous ces mecs et
non mais maintenant les gens qui
critiquent regardez vos têtes
[Applaudissements]
la rigolade c'est que le seul cas des
gonaïves
et merci les gars franchement elle
aurait d abord
bien qu'inattendue des muscles un peu
habité là bas
dominent alain non mais quelle
magnifique magnifique pour éviter
qu'elle ne s'essouffle dans le long
couloir des loges
isabelle demande à ce qu elle
pas franchement c'est matthieu delormeau
n'a beaucoup d'imagés de la vérité est
ce que c'est que l'histoire eddy de
montier le lien ben
c'est pas méchant c'est comme aux
etats-unis quand ce n'est pas étonnant
qu'un attaque thorel pour une petite
voiture tu sais électrique
bah oui c'est vrai là il fallait rester
en rade été bloquée joue est
restée un quart d'heure à lui relais
c'était d'une tristesse
les séries cyril s'enferme souvent plus
d'une heure et ça c'est assez chaud ça
d'une heure avec valérie bénaïm dans sa
loge c'est vrai c'est suivra et personne
à l'autorisation de rentrer il ce soit à
notre code soit ap le bon nombre de fois
à la porte pour cartier ouvre c'est vrai
elle ces
essais maquiller vous arriver de manière
très autoritaire dit valérie bien dans
ma loge c'est là elle disparaît pendant
une heure jusqu'au début de l'émission
on n'a pas le droit de rentrer yann qui
est devant là comme un peloton enfin un
code pour entrer c'est hyper bizarre que
vous écoutez dans vos serveurs c'est
l'année ressort ébouriffés oui mais non
ménage fait une très bonne émission
le manque de mobilité on se on se dit
des choses importantes de la vie voilà
et on y travaille sur le 6 à 7 mai et
s'est fait aux fêtes avec ment pas oui à
alaric mois il va dans sa salle de bain
comme ça et écrits de lambeaux
appartement une chemise alors moi
j'amène une chemise comme ça et il est
torse nu fait merci beaucoup
10 aimerait laissez-moi des chemises tu
vois c'est que ça il fait bouger les com
de cardio
impossible de films je crois que tu as
raison je peux plus à isabelle reçoit
tellement peu d'appels sur son téléphone
elle pense que c'est à cause des gens de
sfr qui lui en voudrai personnellement
et qui aurait bloqué son numéro gilles
c'est toi c'est pas moi mais c'est tout
à fait vrai mais ce numéro c'est
raz-de-marée 46 m2
j'adorerais avoir peu d'appels je
déteste quand le téléphone est vraiment
vous appelle
pas des gens qui savaient ces pardons
îles marshall et gérontophile un non
mais non mathieu met la pression et
géraldine pour qu'elle invite à dîner
avec des gens célèbres intelligent si
géraldine refuse catégoriquement c'est
vrai hier j'ai assisté à une discussion
où ils poursuivent et géraldine dans le
couloir en lui disant je t'en supplie
sors moi dit si je voudrais absolument
dîner avec des gens intelligents et
célèbres et comme tu fais des dîners
chez toi tu avec des gens célèbres et
intelligent invite moi s'il te plaît et
sérieux m'agresser m'ont pas répondu
mais tout objet reste persuadé que la la
le fait que je plafonne un peu dans ma
carrière là quand même
si le monde de réseaux donc
effectivement j'aurais bien dîné avec
françois hollande et tous tes amis
politiques et les gens qui ont du
pouvoir les
politiques pas tu décembre
là il ya un dossier
arrête il ya un doute chez quoi dedans j
sur qui des charges et qu'ils sont moins
savoir plus on peut les miens la source
gilles verdez à la bougie tous là c'est
pas le dossier ah si
jamais je vous jure que j'étais pas au
courant ouais je sais aussi beaucoup
quoi s'est passé mais quelqu'un sur
yoplait aux pressions cela leur est
grave
dans genton
ordures jamais dit quoi sur genton
l'ordure jamais deux sans trois serait
ce qu'il a volé encore
tous leurs maux oui j'étais vous je me
la fermer ou
non
à la tht yeux de leurs mots
auraient esquinté la voiture de cyril
dropsy
et ne lui a jamais avoué et pire ils
auraient fait jouer son assurance pour
que civile sont reconnues responsables
et ainsi éviter à malus pour lui source
e gilles verdez je n'étais pas
moi toute seule elle voiture
dray
ça fait envie
c'est à dire la voiture diego où la
mettrais bien c'est vrai vous ne le
saviez pas c'est un très proche d'entre
vous qui a voulu soulager sa conscience
et qui m'a dit il faut le dire
aujourd'hui sa sé lire cette personne ça
s'est passé que la personne qui vous le
dit c'est yann ça aurait pu être un mais
deux jeux dédiés comme source c'est
diego non je n'aime pas ma source il
faut que la souris d'un fond je veux la
fin les à l'orgue hammond jr histoire et
si la source est important que vous la
donnerais mais j'aurai fini en histoire
et toi tes potes et permet à celles
connaissent mois peut-être épatant c'est
très grave mais comme je déteste ça
pendant un long moment
garez votre voiture dans un parking de
stade ça vous dit quelque chose ça bien
sûr voilà à côté du parc des princes
voilà c'est une voiture de marque
confortable mais pas ostentatoire
il est parti de fuir mais non c est donc
un jour dieu est rentré dans quelle
couleur cette voiture je ne sais je n'ai
pas la couleur de leur moelle quelques
couleurs en voiture et la marque mais
jeunes aura la couleur il ne savait pas
que le rêve et la main mais je n'en
attends rien cuir non non je vais là
chaque modèle en plusieurs couleurs bon
qui sait pas lequel je propose qu elles
demeurées lettres ça commence par un m1
a à z à 0,6 maserati mazeroski dans la
gueule ses doigts il n'avait pu vous là
invendu on passe à autre chose c'est pas
une mégane au nom de mercedes mercedes 1
avez vous quelque chose pour vous même
il est blessé va bien
donc il est rentré dans le parking il a
heurté votre voiture qu'il a légèrement
endommagé mais la sienne était
entièrement rayée sur le côté de ça
il ne nous l'a pas dit il a fait une
déclaration à l'assurance en disant
parce que j'ai lu la déclaration en
disant qu'il avait été heurté par un
conducteur incompétente et sans doute et
sans doute et sans doute dans un état
second qui avait pris la vie ça j'ai pas
dit ça ensuite ensuite l'assurance a
retoqué ça et donc il a été obligé de
donner votre nom il a donné votre mot il
a dit que vous l'aviez orthez qui s'est
fait rembourser il s'est fait
intégralement remboursé vous avez eu un
malus mais comme vous avez trop de
choses à faire on n'avait pas vu que
vous aviez un malware vous avez un malus
tout à fait mais ce que vous avez trop
de voitures rares et faibles en aurait
trop de son nom il était
rentré dedans ça rentre pas là dedans et
s'il est honnête je vais laisser
matthieu delormeau dire ce qu'il a fait
de l'argent ainsi gagné on en avait déjà
déjà est ce que cette histoire est vraie
de lambeaux alors alors c'est en fait je
vous explique je vais demander toutes
les caméras du parking tiens j'ai bah
oui quand j'aurais raconté l'histoire on
va en rire tous les deux
c'est pourquoi c'est après coup c'est
des histoires je m'étais rendu au
parking de ce fameux stade consisterait
pas mais c'est le parc des princes
bordel voilà j'ai tel au moins un sens
c'est le stade français actuellement
mais j'ai assisté parce que j'estime été
mis au moins un savant s'avère qu'en
fait comme tout le moins un s'est vos
voitures
les 12 premières places est ce que
je ne me trompe pas si ça vous des
choses tu peux les abris aussi
j'avais ma smart set quand mon jeu non
mais je crois que je vais tellement pas
voulu accéder c'est pour nous un temps
fort du les gens je vais péter la gueule
je recule à vernir touama manioc des
petits mans je rentre dans le surrey ma
voiture je rentre de là par choix que
j'avais quitté ma voiture a pris combien
je sache je rende gros tu là dessus je
rentre dans le dos de ceux par 5 200 et
mercedes amg je rentre dans le
pare-chocs
ça me plait ne pas la citer et moi ça me
fait chier et donc du court je prends la
plaque et en repartant gpmh erreur que
c'est mon cousin je vous dis voilà s'est
planté g la plaque non et je lui ai dit
on va dire que c'est cette personne qui
m'est rentré dedans au feu ça a été
envoyé à vos assurances est d'ailleurs
merci à vos collaborateurs comme pas
voulu vous déranger avec ça les
assurances se sont mis et on a remboursé
c'est pas énorme et euros quoi il
évoquera si notre cousin vous avez vous
applaudissez la voiture bernard heym à
dix à la voiture d'anna là j'ai dit
effectivement ce qui est vrai et merci
gilles ne le dérange pas vous avez vous
avez une tête comme ça avec les rails
l'attaquant s'était un peu plus d'un an
j'ai touché 778 euros et là où attention
c'est gagnant gagnant c'est pour ça
qu'on mourir tous les deux joueurs valu
ce qu'est ce que j'ai fait cet argent
oui papa beaucoup 5% j'ai eu un malus
oui bah oui vous avez un mail se fait
encore part dont hériteront encore
m
j'ai fait le tuer et là où c'est gagnant
gagnant quelle couleur va contre ma
voiture s'est braqué moi c'était un 4 4
juin pourra classe g 1 tu veux tout
savoir takoucht et de diamants on le
connaît
bref tu sais ce que j'ai fait cet argent
j'étais crevé je m'en voulais aussi ce
qui s'était passé je suis parti une
semaine au maroc c'est quoi alors quand
je suis né quand je suis écouté moi
quand je suis revenu j'étais l'ihf
omeyer et meilleur chroniqueur pour le
même prix qu'avant donc quelque part on
est gagnant gagnant sur cette histoire
et j'ai envie de te dire faute avouée à
demi pardonnée et j'ajouterais il va pas
vous invitiez respecter la bravo et
merci des liens lampre non mais je
voulais pas tomber dans les erreurs et
terry de l'embout va y avoir de
terribles sanctions et quand je dis le
terrible sanction ses deux ferries bleus
sanctions de quel ordre
mes toiles toile a rien eu la tienne moi
ça a puni le pare-chocs mon choix lui a
valu cela correspond à quoi à peu près
comme mon temps je sais pas 3 4 3 à 4000
euros 3 non mais c'est rien mais c'est
la connerie c'est quoi gilles c'est
énorme c'est légal et non et c ont tout
ce que vous avez fait là pour retourner
la feuille est celle où j'ai freiné pour
rien avec me suis jamais vu je n'ai
presque rien tu avais horrible quand tu
m'embrasses en a là rien balaj c'est la
plus chère des mercedes attaque
[Rires]
c'est une blague
cette histoire c'est que comme moi je
vais dans ce stade je sais pas tout les
bagnoles appartiennent encore je recule
devant quelqu'un est qu'au début je me
dis je vais faire cette fraude au mas 1
c'est un mec a plein de thunes je sais
pas que c'est hanouna et j'envoie saaq
sa part dans les cités il contacte chez
vous le rappellera que ce soit cyril ou
pas c'est pas bien là oui c'est moche
bravo vincent alors mes esprits aux
riches pour donner aux pauvres sepang
[Applaudissements]
vous mettez pas rendu compte que vous
aviez quelque chose serait de mauvais
tours selon
tout si je peux me permettre si je peux
me permettre comme ça aussi comme vous
n'êtes pas très précautionneux ce qu'ils
avaient des petits bing un peu sur les
jantes fait pas très attention voiture
ou soutenues sur vous allez pas vous
comment vous
sert il je veux pas vous qu'une personne
ça ne veut pas vous influencer mais
escroquerie à l'assurance mais faux et
usage de faux
ces deux ans de taule je vais appeler la
police
j'appelle la peau bien sûr à faire ces
risques il oublie de dire c'est que vous
avez certainement une procédure de délit
de fuite
rien pas arrêté vous avez un accident
j'ai parlé ni de suite c'est isabelle
mais ce qu'il oublie de dire c'est
qu'ils atteindraient plusieurs fois
d'ailleurs il s'est dit ça marche sur
blada je sais que l'histoire est vraie
elle est allée à crois pas que
d'enseigner qu'on arrive à tous les deux
non
je vais je vais vraiment je pense que
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] un sport travaux
mais pourquoi tu m'appelles commissariat
de boulogne l'atout maître entraînements
non notre plus grosse voiture notamment
ccq riant c'est pas moi qui ai voulu
rencontrer débattre il vous met la fête
et à toutes et tous est cassé